let's say you get a character and you
can't get a beat on it do you ever go
out and find someone you can
emulate well i did it with my when i did
oh brother where are
though joel and eve which i love yeah
it's great i love everything it's a fun
yeah
and joel and ethan called me up and said
he's kind of a hick and i go well i'm
from kentucky man and he says
well you know we really want him to
sound like a hick and i okay
so i took the script and it sent a tape
recorder to my uncle jack
in kentucky he lives in you know
harrisburg kentucky you know
and i said to him i said read the whole
script into this tape recorder
and i'll get you a dialect coach i'll
get you some money and a credit in the
film
and i get the tape back and i play it
and i hear george i don't think folks
around here talk quite like us here but
we'll give her a go
and i'm like there we go i'm done
so you literally had your uncle uh jack
read the
the the script and and you just kind of
learned his way of delivering them
and the funniest part was you know joel
and ethan the way they write you don't
really improvise their stuff because
it's so well written you don't mess with
it right
and i was doing a scene and joel comes
over and because i'm like you know
i'm talking to like delmar or del mar
where the heck are you you wearing the
dang deal are you
hey
and they they they came over and they
said
i got a question for you man why is it
that you say
every word exactly as we've written it
except hell or damn
i was like what you don't say hell or
damn i uh i don't
you go no and i went back and listened
to tape and it's he's
and when he said i don't think people
talk like this around here he meant they
don't curse
they don't say hell or damage so he made
the heck and dirt
he rewrote the children they thought